hey guys it's Justine and I'm here with
the RO today we are going to do a
blindfold wreath decorating we have done
some blindfolded things in the past and
one of my favorite videos still today is
we decorated a Christmas tree
alright I'm gonna put this around the
tree okay this is not the Christmas
you're not that one hurry did this is a
new one but that one was pretty epic we
decorated it blindfolded she was wrapped
up in like it stuck in a tree but I'll
tell you what I thought okay let's do
something like that but maybe on a
smaller scale
I've never decorated a wreath before and
say really never cool never we have some
mystery items so I don't know what is in
the mystery bag overnight decorate oh
and we've lost our names I'm reading in
the line folding no yeah so before like
I knew all the stuff that we had and we
saw it ahead of time this time we don't
even know what it is
I've never decorated a wreath before I
just bought them as a wreath me too i
decorate a tree before so i kind of had
some understanding of what to do I don't
know what to do with this thing I don't
know either just attach stuff to it I'm
assuming depending upon the stuff that
we have there a top or a bottom or is it
just all solid you can just hang it from
wherever I think you can just hang it
from wherever yeah it looks like that
okay like there's not like a top of the
Christmas tree so I can't really mess
something up in that regard we're gonna
find out so I guess let's put our
blindfolds on and Mike would you be so
kind as to bring in our items Mike what
did you did you go to Michael's I hear
something
do you think we're gonna need scissors a
lot of stuff I'm feeling a bag here and
I don't know how to open it we not
figure it out I guess
oh my gosh - lookie Thanks
Dewey is this time or do we just go I
think we just go until we feel like
we're sick of doing it open this bag
okay oh very careful just see here give
me your hand I think these are fuzzy
pipe cleaners feeling oh we're
definitely getting there's a lot of them
okay I'm gonna take a few out since
you're holding the bag this is nice
yeah they're little pokey at the end coz
of like the wire we in the world is this
are you holding let me feel it's big
it's been think of a Christmas ornament
but like why is it so freaking big I'm
gonna put this on my tree whoa what's
happening over there I don't know I'm
trying to feel what this is I think it's
like feel that there's holes in there
yeah I'm over here what is this brick Oh
what is it I don't know it feels like a
hamster ball oh I got a pinecone and it
just poked to me yeah but good boy hope
for things so what else do we have
oh this is like a bow and
oh I empty I think I know what this is
this is a ball some sort of Christmas
lights because I feel the tag we're just
gonna stick things in here is this on or
off is it light weight are you late
what oh of course you found the techie
thing is when you got the lights is this
a liar I don't know but there's no off
switch I don't feel a not yet arrest
which flip it over oh I feel what I have
lashes on or off if you hold it up
really close to making it sound no it
doesn't make any music oh okay
I saw some light is it on I don't know
now
oh shoot my trying to get it wait that's
on I did touch it now okay wait it's
blinking it's blinking yeah oh you know
what there must be multiple settings
what the heck is this well I think this
might be like a big light bulb because
it's all seems like it's one thing oh my
gosh this is really wait this is bad
idea what is this a cane
why would what is the and it feels
glittery I think it's a candy cane
it's like I'm gonna do jello I want to
feel it but I'm doing something right
now and if I move my fingers I mean
maybe I can tack it on here okay five
liters it's honestly amazing okay I'm
gonna attach these it's the only way I
can get stuff to stick on here okay I
can do this I can do this this reminds
me of middle school crafting time oh my
goodness I was always really bad at it
okay got a few my reef tier how much
spun in your it hitting because I'm
going side that's money just you can put
me in a reef
that's something I can put in here yeah
you can put me in there
I've never decorated a wreath before so
I'm not really sure what the etiquette
you know what I was really hoping to
take a wreath decorating class you're
taking one now maybe this is a little
advanced yeah this buys my ring so heavy
now what is this Oh
sob you jam it Oh are these more lights
Oh keep finding all the lights I don't
have a meal annual maybe I want to be
red Oh you feeling lights 151 okay I'm
taking one and I'm gonna wrap the time
then take one as well are you gonna trip
out and you we open our eyes and we've
created the best-looking Rives anyone's
ever seen I have very low hope see I
like to set my expectations super low so
right now let's see if it's really low
so maybe we'll be surprised what is this
Justine I'm gonna make a masterpiece so
you just oh oh my gosh my leg is stuck
I'm so sorry I've got a couple of long
I'm stringing them together like
Rapunzel hair or something
I keep getting pinched holiday
decorations are very pokey like
Christmas trees and ornaments and
everything pine cones are all pokey why
do people make them pokey they shall be
soft so I can't see but I think that
this may be the blindfold that I was
missing earlier wait really
yeah here touch it let me see it let me
see definitely the delightful ah this is
this is not long enough oh that's and I
got the bow that's a humongous bow
that's like a bow that you stick on a
new car and you're like surprised and it
has the big big big bow on it maybe I'll
put this on my cyber truck I was so
excited for your cyber truck my crazy
you have to wait so long I don't mind
how long do you have to wait 20:21
twit yeah
that is a while no one's gonna want it
yeah I might have my Arabian but Maria
is so nice like honestly I don't really
think the cyber truck looks that good
yep some people are saying they're being
big haters on the cyber truck Oh stupid
but I'm like it's really awesome you
guys definitely something I keep getting
pinched
why don't I don't know what it's gonna
look like you guys were bleeding Mike is
there any blood do you see any blood
anywhere okay we're doing great then
because I feel a really pinch again I'm
gonna try I'm trying to weave this
through I think I'm a little bit my
Reaves caught on your reef a little bit
but what did you find
wait let Sammy laughs what's happening
oh my gosh what is this do we use
everything sighs I feel this I thought I
stuck this in my reef but apparently not
they're gonna start putting a magnet
around 8:06 do not eat that okay this is
just a decoration one I'm gonna make a
great holiday reef and I'm gonna hang it
from my know we're gonna scare your door
don't know that's not what are you
supposed to hang from your mouth look
Karen that's not the Pope where do you
let your wreath or your door right I
don't think it has a song windows I put
them on the windows on the inside of the
house too
if you need a pipe cleaner I've got a
ton of them right now are you pretty
satisfied with my amount that's already
attacking on you presents for me yeah
you can have this research okay this
entire video is me stringing pipe
cleaners together and looping them
around my dream okay now what do I do do
it now I've got a candy cane some lights
I've got some lights on here I think
that I'm done because I think I did oh
oh gosh oh gosh I don't know what it is
dangling in the middle of my grave how
do you fill it you think you're I use is
done
I've gotten everything okay ready I'm
scared and I'm sentimental if I actually
like hang up what we made I have so much
stuff on my freakin holiday craft just
the whole spew of it this is not even
where's the reef I'm just seeing a set
oh we have to hate we have to show oh my
gosh so wait this looks like what I have
spells in my backyard and they nest and
this looks like a squirrel nest they
just find everything that they clean up
oh it's a bell oh it is but it's it's
living or down mice an ornament - so
what I don't even know how I got in
there oh oh oh
ours are connected oh and I thought you
were giving me my own light don't even
lights okay this definitely was all
those are pinecones I thought these were
big like light bulbs disco balls you
have disco balls do you have like some
oh my god remphan okay I need to hold
this up Wow okay so our ribs are
connected I thought these were lights I
thought I had my own lights
wait did you actually have light so I
felt a battery pack wait there are more
light oh this is so cute I missed it we
don't know all right because I think
that I set all of my my grease on top of
all the items listen here this is so
cute are you kidding me
they would go really well on like a
double door yeah there's you know who
else is on here um I feel like I just
had everything and I stuck it on this is
happy sweet because we have the donut we
have the candy cane so my reef is happy
sweet jingle balls Christmas this whole
event has everything though oh my god
the little snowmen on here this is
really ridiculous
javis crazy you want to hang this off it
is that yeah I will I will hang that up
don't even tease me I will do it it'll
look so
you can hang them right back here check
this out oh my gosh what's your theme
freakin a swirl nest this is like a
hoarders holiday well let me give you
these two back pinecones these fell on
the ground so we didn't even see these I
like us to feel these we didn't field
these oh I felt them they were pulled
you did you tossed up do you smell oh
there's mice they smell like cinnamon
yummy I am feeling super festive now and
I just don't even know how to contain my
holiday excitements you can keep these
here with me
okay well we also made a video in Rose
channel where we decorated a massive
gingerbread house like this is a mansion
it's a Frankenstein gingerbread creation
I wanted to combine all the gingerbread
houses I could find into one and we did
it we did so go check that out open the
link in the description and annotation
so make sure you guys go check it out
and be sure to go say hi to ro and
subscribe to our Channel
I think that's it give Wow
do you like a cozy squirrel's nest vibe
or a sweet jingle balls vibe let us know
in the comments we'll see you later
my buddy
you
[Music]